[Music]
musicians are making the Kovach 19
lockdown more bearable for everyone
dancers are sharing their art through
these difficult times writers keep
broadening our horizons and yet during
the lockdown people working in the
cultural and creative sectors are some
of the worst hit across Europe cultural
events have been canceled
making it impossible for artists to earn
a living the EU is lending up to 100
billion euros to Member States to
protect workers affected by the pandemic
through the new emergency unemployment
program ashore rules for structural
funds have also been amended to combat
the economic impact of the pandemic the
challenge now is to channel some of
these funds to the cultural sector we
need more flexibility in the programme
so that the cultural sector with its
special approach can be supported the
isolations should not come at the cost
of culture MEP s want to protect artists
who may not qualify for national support
schemes through creative Europe they are
asking the Commission to increase the
existing fund Parliament is also
proposing to create an emergency fund to
support the media and press sector many
artists are sharing free performances
online to help us through the crisis
[Music]
they deserve a financial help for the
hard days ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]